The Joe Rogan Experience so they lead
you from a Hut you're staying down they
stop they go stop listen to the insects
and the river
he goes that's going to be Amplified
soon
I know okay
he comes and they the woman uh the
shaman wears his headdress and and she
beats you with these leaves and rubs his
uh says whatever chance she says and
rubs a stone all over you
gives you the Ayahuasca tastes like
[ __ ] ass tastes like whatever's left
in this ashtray and you just drink it
down they say your partner other side of
the fire you're on this side of the fire
you don't talk
he's having his trip you're having hit
your trip that's it
um
um you might throw up because that is
the Ayahuasca doesn't make a trip the
Ayahuasca takes everything out of you
and then the
Chom I have written down actually
kruna was the that's a different drug
yeah so ayahuasa clears you unless it's
a chakruna in this case do it they
showed they showed me where the iOS came
from planted 80 years before
they planted it so
drank it I'm laying there on a mat it's
just like a thin thin mat next to this
fire in this like Hut
um
I don't I I'm a bit worried about like
anacondas and jaguars and stuff but like
um
so she says the shama says I'm your
mother here the Ayahuasca the root is
your grandmother
my son who's who's training to be a
shaman he is your brother and the fire
is your ancestors
um
so I drank it he said stare at the fire
for about five minutes then go lay down
my partner started throwing up 10
minutes in going to the edge there's two
entrances to the thing just throwing up
I just wasn't coming it wasn't coming a
little bit of like a light cap and a
stem mushroom feel
for about
I don't know hour and a half or so and
then I started getting nauseous but I
started I'm trying to choke it down like
don't don't and then it hit me like oh I
think I'm supposed to like supposed to
throw up
so I kind of like pitch black I mean
away from the fire went to the the edge
and then like you know how you can like
sort of like and then barf like a little
bit and then just unload it
I was afraid it would be like wretching
and wretching it wasn't that
um just like unloaded and then he's
right there the Shaman's like trainee
son with a bowl of water he was swish
around don't drink it and he goes uh are
you having visions
dude I don't know how he was
I don't know how he's communicating to
be honest because he didn't I barely
speak Spanish and he barely speaks
Spanish
but it enough I guess
I was like he was like you're having
visions and I was like yeah they're more
like kind of mental like the mental
mushrooms and mental and he goes okay go
back be strong
I don't know how he was conveying this
to me
but he was like okay go be strong go lay
down there and like you have to like be
strong
so then it just
opened up
and so more than an hour and a half in
more than an hour and a half in of a
seven hour trip wow
um
yeah it took a while
the partner was going immediately but
like uh
I see these like fractals and like and
the K and geometric shapes and
occasional like splashes of and this is
the thatch roof of the Hut right so
nothing's there
and an occasional like real splash of
like Vivid neon light
and then I started seeing these like
orbs kind of like going up into the
fractals and then the more I looked
forward and back I'm on my back but more
like forward backwards side to side
there's just hundreds or thousands of
these these orbs these small orbs going
up
into the fractals and just sort of like
playing with each other
these orbs they were kind of like had a
life to them
so like and then at some point from me
comes this orb and sort of like goes up
and then I start examining what the orbs
are
so
look I don't know I don't know about any
of this stuff
but this is just what it gave me I don't
know you know same as mushrooms I don't
know if it's just scientific or if it's
like a another realm whatever right
the orbs
were
I call it when you pure something when
you pure it
to me they were they were moments of of
pure artistic expression
do you ever have a
cassette or or a roll where you're like
I hit every [ __ ] move you get in the
zone you in the zone sure you cured it
you know uh in golf Jamie you might know
it was like when you [ __ ] hit one and
you're just like [ __ ] like oh but
you're like I can't hit the Green from
here you do see it Go perfectly and
bounce and it's just a pure moment of
artistic expression and generally when I
see that it makes me cry when I listen
to never mind I I I start I know I tear
up you know you ever hear that album
when you're like oh this is they nailed
it they nailed it they nailed it uh uh
uh cigar de familia in Barcelona this
church that was it's being built still
it's a 200 year plan to build this the
perfect Church Saint Peter's Basilica in
Rome okay and you see it stunning and I
wept in there I just thought I mean I
started weeping start crying yeah it's
like I I don't know it's just like it's
overwhelmingly perfect it's art yeah
other moments I was at um
the um not to be big moments it could be
small moments I was at the um haunted
ride at Disney
back in L.A and I was with some chick
and I was like some guy was like who
read this was uh you know and like pitch
he's playing the role whatever and then
like he left to go greet the next like
car and as we were slowly moving forward
and then I was like oh that was creepy
right and then he was back on me just
like what did you say it just like
frightened me and I'm like that guy
nailed it in that moment we were both
[ __ ] jumped he [ __ ] nailed it
right he peered it
and what you want in those moments you
did it right you made this thing and
that's the orb and what you want is
to make it for sure what you also want
is
some recognition
you want someone to say like if you hit
that golf shot you look around like if
you're playing by yourself and somebody
that next he's like dude [ __ ] nice
one you're like yes thank you you saw it
you saw it right
and so
there's been two things I've gotten that
way
two things that I've had that I'm like I
I pureed it
um
one was that storytelling show
this is not happening I I just think it
was like
I I mean I don't want to talk about
myself but like it was cool and it the
nail was a way for for other Comics to
show themselves I can express it for you
you did an amazing thing and those
opening sequences where you'd have like
these animated fight scenes and [ __ ]
they were awesome we're cool we just
made it cool and fun to watch and I let
people go hey we're not gonna censor you
right we want you to do your thing
you're a [ __ ] uh strip club in the
wood story is like these moments that
I'm also allowing other people to like
so I figured out my orbs what I do is
make stuff myself and then also give a
chance for other people to make theirs
it's one of my things I like making you
have the same thing where you like
having other people make their thanks
it's one of your art forms is allowing
other people to make their art
another one was this last hour I did the
Jew hour
it was it was good it was really [ __ ]
it was good
and so it would have bothered me at the
time I wasn't able to like make it as
special
but I was able in that moment ago
but I made it it was good you know I
made a really [ __ ] really mindful
kind of perfect thing and yeah maybe
whatever happened like I wasn't able to
make like millions of people saw it but
like
thousands of people saw it maybe 150 000
people saw it live you know
but like I made it
and I cried hard
for that for this is not happening not
so much that like for the loss but for
like
for like when I I was able to Purity I
was able to step back and go like it's
done now I made it and it hit me like oh
damn dude that was [ __ ] good
and I just kind of say goodbye to it and
that orb went up
and and played for eternity every time
you do something like artistically pure
like that and nail it you pure it
those things are up there in the heavens
and the whatever
they're playing with each other all the
forms the guy at Disney the guy who made
the Basilica
uh [ __ ] Kurt Cobain never mind not
kirkobe never mind is up there playing
with each other
enjoying each other's company forever
and I saw myself in 50 years dead
and the orbs is still playing and I'm
decaying and the orbs are still playing
they'll be there forever
and I was able to sort of like
put that behind me and say I'll move on
to my next thing because what I want to
do is I want to make things
right I want to make another orb and
that's kind of all I want to do now is
just make another thing and I won't
always get there but even if you fail
even if you're like ah set was so so you
know what's getting you closer to a
[ __ ] perfect set and sometimes it's
just a 15 minute set at the [ __ ]
whatever Club you know uh the governors
or some [ __ ] where it's like oh I
[ __ ] nailed that sometimes it's a 10
minute pop in you're like that
earthquake thing that I saw at the haha
that was one because there was some kid
some young one-year comic watching that
going like oh my God he [ __ ] peered
it in that moment yeah but you wanted
someone to [ __ ] notice it once in a
while you just you do
catch new episodes of The Joe Rogan
Experience for free only on Spotify
watch back catalog JRE videos on Spotify
including Clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and audio experience on
Spotify you can listen to the JRE in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all for free Spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new JRE episodes you
just need to search for the JRE on your
Spotify app go to Spotify now to get
this full episode of The Joe Rogan
Experience